[Music]
now they've got the best part um I have
to tell you guys I had like the biggest
kool-aid grin on my face when I walked
out of this movie I mean seriously I was
just I was happy first of all it was fun
the movie was fun and it was funny and I
just felt like I didn't feel it as good
making it as I felt watching it like
with you all together it did and I feel
that it really did I mean you never know
how something's gonna translate but
certainly with movies like this where
there's so much I mean it wasn't there
was a lot of special effects in movie
but there's a lot of precision needed
for the kinds of things we were doing
shooting things can take days and days
to shoot like one scene or in the movie
but the great thing about being around
these eight people is like no one is shy
and everyone's so chatty and there's the
eight most interesting women I think in
Hollywood so it was really fun to be on
set even during the times that were slow
there were no egos and everybody yeah
and everybody just had each other's
backs and everybody wanted the other one
to shine and it was just like I I'm so
happy that we all met through work but I
would just be set to join be friends
with you guys and really I know if we
didn't know working I know yeah yeah
because I think we've heard from all of
you all about this group text that
doesn't we don't know we don't we don't
know we have balance well listen Sandra
spilled the beans she say y'all did
delete it but you went through and said
okay we gotta get rid of this give there
may be hackers yeah I think more I
introduced the idea that maybe like wait
a second are we inviting people to yeah
well Nora was like guys what if somebody
like tries to steal my phone yeah I mean
that is a great point so yes we may or
may not have another one somewhere
somewhere maybe in the universe in the
universe at some planet maybe just
telepathy we are actually so we um we
reached out to some fans just to see
like what they would ask you what they
wanted to know if they were you know
interviewing you guys and so we got our
favorite response
and I know Entertainment Tonight we're
real high-tech I couldn't get it to play
so I had to put up my phone so I'm gonna
give it to you guys if you can just push
play in the heavens yeah that's got any
question talented I promise I want to
know
who has actually stolen something in
their life on the spot thank you she was
just letting it that was like a Rihanna
mom I have you have okay
spill it I can't decide which time there
was the high school thievery that was
happening and then there was like the
childhood thieving that was happening
like that's a high school Oh see I was
thinking I would do the other get sued
by the clothing company that I used to
steal from on Columbus Avenue [ __ ]
when you were in high school you would
shoplift clothes in one clothing I just
did it once successfully it was a body
in velvet body city in a snap crotch but
I was like it was a couple of my friends
and I did it together butyou know did
you are lil a Belva body because the one
and then share yeah we all stole about
it Bobby
no they're probably better people than
my i gen you my my never go in my brain
and i genuinely cannot remember that you
did something swearing at some some very
expensive watch for some story you know
i don't know this out god I don't want
to tell us this just confirms
everybody's worst feelings about me but
I steal books from movies feel like a
book will you be oh we got transported
from by a book and you'll take home with
you as a memory yeah but you think I
probably did have it he wouldn't give it
to you
I stole you know the glasses I wear at
the end of the movie no cuz I can see me
oh right why wear glasses at the end of
the movie yeah I stole those I know I
can take this now bad I'm so bad I don't
have clothes for them at that I think I
know a lot I still some because I bought
a lot of them shoes but I stole some
clothes from the mini-project Universal
whoever stole my employers yeah there's
a couple items that I stole
I bought the expensive stuff but there's
like a couple Lauren I don't feel like
you deserve that you work for that yeah
yeah
thank you know do you take I needed
another body singer Rihanna I don't know
that when she asked the question it was
loaded college it actually she said
because she knew that lots of people
would see it she wanted to be a little
more tame because what she really wanted
to ask
oh that's now I really know a story yeah
like they went straight into our
territory real fast so we don't have any
polite stories so this is all about like
a heist so if you could steal the closet
from another star who would that be
and why would you want that closet from
another star or movie or just another
shift in Jinja well you can use your
mother sharona's closets Gwen Stefani
mmm really yeah I think so at least I
paying more attention I thought that
Beyonce's post baby stuff yeah I mean
listen like she was dressing there's
like photo shoots for she was like
they're the most of them yes amazing
seizure are directed photo shoot also
but but that look like somebody just
like snapped is selfie yeah it's right
where she'll wear like an oversized
sweatshirt at Coachella like her
Coachella Beyonce's Coachella looks very
good I would scale those looks weren't
those cool oh yeah yeah yeah okay I have
another one to Blake Lively I just said
I want your way okay so also I want to
know because you guys borrow so much
jewelry what's the most expensive
jewelry that you've ever borrowed and
what would you have done if you lost it
so I lost joy I went to the Met Gala in
like 2012 and the theme was Punk'd he
saw the whole story is it like it's a
great story yeah I you had to wear like
it was Punk so my interpretation of punk
was like lots of rings but like one of
the rings that I wore in my pinky finger
what it was actually too big and yes
you've been wearing it on index finger
and when I when I left and I got home
that night I
you got my rings I was like something's
missing so put on sweatpants I still
have my makeup and hair on and I went
back up to the met from downtown I love
done in New York and I went back up to
the mat as a completely different
experience and like so as a complete
anonymous person that like and actresses
and famous people were still there like
elbowing me out of the way I got in your
sweatpants I was wearing my sweatpants
and it's not shirt and nobody knew who I
was because I was so and I'm just
wearing sneakers didn't find the ring it
was it's a truly terrible story did you
have what I had the time you take my
ring I know I didn't have an insurance
it was it that experience yeah that's
bad okay yeah the bodysuit I stole was
39 million it just wasn't that it's fun
yeah I just want everyone to know it
wasn't oh my god okay
[Music]